the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and again look you know I
love what I do thank God I'm still here
and uh I can't thank you guys enough for
all your support so please hit that
subscribe on the YouTube channel keep
watching keep telling everybody we're
doing something important over here all
right if you have to have more then
you've got to check out the patreon I
know I say it every week here but I I
think it every week on that show what
are we gonna hear that's different from
last week and every week you all [__]
bring the heat so it's called the
Honeydew of y'all it's your stories and
they're the wildest [__] stories of
anything I've ever heard in my life it's
only five bucks a month and if you sign
up for a year now you'll get over a
month free you get the Honeydew a day
early you get an ad free and you get it
at no additional cost all right and if
you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to then go listen to my old
podcast the crab Feast yeah I'm
promoting an old podcast it's a seven
and a half year library and if you
listen to two episodes a week still
going to take you three years to get
through it okay
so go listen subscribe it's a great
storytelling podcast and that's the biz
here now you guys know what we're doing
over here I always say we highlight the
low lights and these are the stories
behind the storytellers I am very
excited to have this guest on today
first time here on the Honeydew ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome me in
finance welcome to the honeymoon
thank you for having me brother I'm
excited to be here dude how about the
walk up outside that was it could not
have been planned better if if someone
wrote that the screw like this is too
nice this is two it was just and also I
didn't see you were behind a tree yeah
so you just appeared you just appeared
out of nowhere I get out of my car I get
a cane you come on yeah I'm on right
hand you're on left hand you get a joint
I got a cigarette I'm like is this a
sunglasses regular glasses I mean the
drinks Chick-fil-A Starbucks it is just
a mirror of unbelievable it was
incredible it was wild
it was awesome it was like inside out
parallel universe I [__] loved it
totally it was it was amazing uh well
thank you very much for being here
um I'm glad you're doing well after that
but uh before we get into whatever we're
gonna talk about plug promote everything
you'd like please give it all you can
follow me on Instagram Twitter and
twitch ianimal69
uh ianfinance.com for all my dates and I
have a great podcast Being Ian with
Jordan uh my best friend Jordan Jensen
and I she's a great comic we um have
brain parasites and art just rap brain
and ADHD and it's a lot of fun and uh I
also have bye guys on gas digital with
uh me and Zach amiko and uh yeah I got a
lot of dates coming up I'm super excited
I'm on the road every weekend until like
June and uh I'm shooting a special in
New York City
well also I want to uh throw out a
congrats you because you just sold out
to Hollywood improv on Sunday yeah and
that's a [__] that's huge yeah thanks
I said it feels it feels incredible to
fly into a major city a major city and
sell out their Comedy Club yeah it was
it was truly magical man it was amazing
I I got a static Ovation at the end and
I had the mic in the crowd and we're
doing a sing-along to one of my favorite
hardcore hands I'm like in my head I'm
like should I stage dive should I just
you know I fall on this 23 year old like
Instagram model like okay never mind
for you yeah it was really neat and my
my good buddies were there and it was
just such a you know to be able to put
my friends on the show and make it like
such a fun hang was like so cool you
know and I love watching my friends do
stand up and have a good time and so I I
yeah I appreciate that thank you Ryan
yeah good for you it was great those are
the good times let's talk about the [__]
show let's get into it let's go
uh well so just outside talking to you I
found out you're from Delaware Delaware
not a lot of delawareans that I'm that
really come out of there so much I know
there's Aubry Plaza Aubry Plaza Delaware
a guy named Joey
yeah
that's what I am dog you know uh-huh so
tell me about your world what's it like
growing up uh as Ian in Delaware
man I don't know man it's it's it's just
the same place as everywhere else you
know you find your own fun you do your
own thing and then you leave as soon as
you can but I mean specifically for you
your mom and dad are married at the time
you're living in Delaware that's where
you're born yeah yeah okay yeah born and
raised in Delaware and uh the place
where I was baptized is the same place
where my parents got married and where
we had my dad's funeral and it was you
know you talk about full circle yeah
right it is yeah yeah are you an only
child I'm an only child in Delaware uh
Mom and Dad amazing family my childhood
was like so idyllic my dad would come
home from work I'd run out of the house
the dog would run around them my mom
would be at the door he'd come home he
was all-time quarterback all the kids
would play football at my house you know
snow days he's everybody in the
neighborhood love John you know and uh
what did he do for a living he was a
train inspector for CSX oh oh [__] okay
yeah and uh so I lived in Delaware and
he would drive back and forth to Philly
every day for work and uh it's full
circle again I started comedy in Philly
and every night I'm driving back and
forth now from Delaware except he was
coming from just sobbing family's house
with a wife and a kid and I'm literally
coming from a halfway house because I
burn my life down driving to and from
Delaware my dad's making a living
supporting his family I'm doing Open Mic
for free
paying 400 bucks a week because I'm
living in a [__] halfway house
oh
you know yeah
and the halfway house I lived in was
directly across the street from the
bowling alley my mom threw me my
surprise 18th birthday party and I'm
just like how did I get here at 18 I
have friends get over here I'm like I
wish instead of a bowling ball it was a
crystal ball yeah
it's like you know okay I'm talking I'm
talking a 40-foot walk yeah I'm I'm in
the halfway house I got to be home by 10
p.m because I'm on curfew you know and
I'm getting my chores done I'm out on
the board smoking cigarettes next to a
pagan meth dealer and I'm looking like
where did I go wrong you know it's like
a gnarly but that's Delaware baby
it's just like growing up everywhere
else
[Laughter]
uh-huh
okay let's go back to Childhood yeah
all right um now you I you sent your
bullet points in so you lose your dad at
eight your dad dies when you're eight
how does your dad pass away uh he died
in an accident work on the train yard no
yeah how's North do you mind talking
about it
um or at least you don't have to get
like specific but yeah was he run over
was no no there is there was I mean it's
so funny with these trains arailments
everyone's talking about safety
regulations and it's like man
[__] happens and then change is made you
know my my dad died and then afterwards
they were like oh maybe we should put
some safety regulations on this you know
and the funny thing is where he died in
Philly
is now in Ikea no so I you know to go
see where he died I have to be like hey
you tell me how to put together a couch
how do you put together a broken family
you know anyone
look at him you know
but uh matter of fact dude I headlined
the Philly punch line it was amazing all
my guys I started with him Philly came
and you know I I sold well it was like
Oh Boy comes home you know it's a fun
game yeah and we went to IHOP on a
Sunday and I got to like buy breakfast I
was like man and then I'm putting it
together I go oh my God
I can walk from this IHOP to where my
dad died this is crazy it was like such
a moment of like things coming together
and I didn't I went I didn't cry I
didn't know sad dude I went I laughed I
talked to him bought three futons but
three futons I brought over eggs for him
I brought over moons on my hammy you
know and uh dude I got shot with these
memories because I saw the big like
Warehouse because he they I remember
like take your kid to work day and he
like brought me up and dude I got this
vision of us pulling up in the truck
getting out me going seeing his locker
and and I saw the building it's all like
dilapidated you know and it was it was
just such a [__]
I don't know it was a really a friend
asked me and they go how does that make
you feel oh my God I'm so sorry and and
honestly man and this is you know like
comedy's great this and that cool
awesome but the thing I'm most proud of
man is is they go how does that make you
feel and I go at peace
and that is such an amazing achievement
because I spent it's coming up on three
decades
30 years on May 20th and I spent so long
in like anger and sadness and loss and
uh man to come back and have all those
things lining up it was just beautiful I
I got no other feeling but but gratitude
and happiness yeah you know which which
I never thought I would get and I'll
tell you what if you don't get there it
doesn't line up like that either because
you don't see it yeah you're just
looking through a different filter of
anger and rage yeah and and also I was
the same way too like I didn't even
realize sometimes how angry I was and
I'm like oh yeah you think that's just
normal in my family you know yeah [__] I
didn't know that one yeah well dude
alcohol like blew my life up but I'm
like thankful for it because getting to
the bottom of a bottle I could finally
be like sad and release emotion and like
that I would get drunk and like yell at
him in the sky and access this thing and
uh dude talk about anger I used to I was
like such an angry driver just go up and
like slap drinks out of people's hands
for no reason trying to fight like come
on hit me like dude insane insane insane
oh yeah I yeah I did do you know how
many times I've cartoonishly gotten
thrown out of a bar like the old heave
Hoe by the bouncers you know just for
slapping drinks and [__] oh dude
right now visions of just a fist coming
up my face from a bouncer and I'm like I
deserved it you know
yeah it's [__] crazy all right wait I
want to take you back to a time that
might be uncomfortable for you but
you're eight years old how do you find
out that your dad is dying man well this
is a trip
so
strengths are tight enough you bring
your passport cause we're going on a
journey
uh my dad and I were
best friends I mean this guy was my guy
there was a connection there that again
man I knew him for eight years and we
were closer in that than friends of mine
that had their dad their whole life I
got friends that have dads they might as
well be dead
and this guy man when I was born uh I
was in the hospital for 30 days I like
jaundice I was on this machine I was the
incubator he wrote me a letter every day
um that I didn't see until I was like in
my 20s and uh no yeah and before he
would leave yeah yeah he had to be yeah
bro get to it and I every day before we
left for work he'd write me a note on a
legal pad just me write a note to me and
my mom and you know make jokes and
everything and like talk about the day
before or whatever and how he's excited
about the weekend this and that every
day before he went to work I have stacks
of these letters
and um he and I were just so close man
we would have guys weekend at the beach
where it was like he and I would just go
to the beach uh in Rehoboth Delaware and
uh we would the last day we'd wake up to
watch a sunrise over the beach and uh
you know we we were always incredibly
close and the way I would get out of
trouble when I was younger is I would
imitate him I would make him laugh and
then he couldn't be mad you know that's
what my [__] daughter does to me yeah
yeah she imitates her mom I go what do I
do she goes you go get to bed and I go
oh
I do [__]
[__] go yeah
yeah dude I started laughing so yeah oh
yeah you're lucky I
would just I I would go at dinner I
would go damn it boy
you know yeah and uh so he and I we were
[__] synced up locked in right and so
the uh
day before he died my aunt died my grade
my aunt says so it was his aunt and uh
we just reconnected with that part of
his family because his dad was a bad
alcoholic
and he told his dad he said look you're
not meeting my son so you get your life
together so I didn't mean my grandfather
until I was like seven a couple months
before he died
and I sat on his lap and this guy was so
beat up from like alcohol on drugs I sit
on slap in the first thing I said I go
pop up are you a robber
[Laughter]
[Music]
but uh a matter of fact when that dude
was dying in the hospital I'll never
forget this we me and my dad and my
grandpop's like brothers and everything
we were all in the room he's in the bed
and he goes and he couldn't talk and he
just like mumbled something and all of
us just broke down laughing I just
remember like that moment of like
laughter brought These Fine dance men
together you know it was like really
cool and so uh we connected with his
side of the family and the day before my
dad died my aunt sis died so we're all
you know at the house talking and uh
really I don't mean interrupt but your
great aunt dying the day before your
father is that your first experience
with death no no my grandfather my dad's
dad died in like 91. how old were you
then uh six man so you're getting it six
seven eight yeah but but I I saw that
was it like I only saw my dad cry two
times when he was when his dad died and
uh when he had knee surgery and I just
heard him on the steps going down the
steps because he was like in such pain
you know but uh
he
so yeah my my ancest died we're all at
the house and you know I from a young
age dark humor and you know Gallows
humor was what got us through and we're
like laughing because my dad's like boy
you better hope I go before your mom
because if not you're in for a world of
hurt because my mom was very like coddle
you know my dad was like the strict I
had like these like Rule and I loved it
I loved the the discipline and like you
know like bedtimes and like rules you
know I work better on structure and I've
you know after he died I never had it
yeah and uh you know we're all laughing
about that and everything and the next
morning I uh
I
I wake up and it's like 4 30 in the
morning he's getting ready for work and
I go to the bathroom I go Dad don't go
to work today stay home with me I'll
take off from school please don't go to
work and I'm hugging his leg begging him
not to go to work and he's going no no
no I go something bad's gonna happen and
goes you're just upset you said this
yeah you're just upset that ancest died
it's okay tug me into bed and goes I'll
pick you up after school we had baseball
and you know I love you and we we kiss
goodbye and then I go to sleep
and I have a dream that he died
are you [__] I swear to God something
I swear to God then you go to bed a
dream about this
I dream he dies do you remember the
dream do you remember how I just
remember him dying okay and I was very
like I loved God when I was younger like
I wanted to be a priest you know well
you really love God
my parents gave me like a cartoon
picture Bible and to punish me they'd
take it away like it was you know like I
used to get picked on and my dad was
like you gotta fight these kids back and
I'm like but Jesus
yeah like total take that [__]
goddamn mortal dude
[Laughter]
so I'm gay dude I was so gay for God it
was out of control man like Jesus
[Music]
gonna be a big seller in the Midway yeah
oh yeah oh [__] I uh I was gay for God
and I dreamed he died and I woke up and
I remember sitting up and going oh my
God thank God it was a dream
my dad would never die God would never
let that happen to my family
and uh that morning I don't remember
this but my mom says that morning he
kept calling the house to check in and
like make us laugh my mom was like you
better get you're gonna get fired We're
Not Gonna you know
have any any money to live you better go
get back to work and he just kept
calling I love you guys I love you
and then uh
I had that dream I said God would never
let that happen to my family
and uh I went to school
and I'm going to the bathroom early in
the morning and this girl stops me a
grade younger than me my mom is a
teacher's aide at my school okay
and so I was in second grade my mom was
a teacher's aide in first grade and this
first grader comes up to me when I'm
going to the bathroom she goes are you
in finance I go yeah and she goes your
mom had to leave school because your dad
got in an accident
that's how you found out I
I just knew they said accident
I just knew
and I started just wailing and uh a
teacher had to come up and go no no no
you're you're
um Mom you know your aunt sis died so
your dad was just feeling upset so that
everybody's at your aunt's sister's
house it's it's okay and I'm like uh-huh
and then uh I go back to class and
there's an announcement over the speaker
Ian Finance please report to the main
office and I [__] knew I [__] knew
and I tried so hard to posture and like
I put my achilles hat on backwards and I
was like I get to leave have fun in
school you know just making it out like
I'm the lucky one you know
and uh you know my my mom and my
grandfather were there and in the
morning that day it was like so
sunny and then when I go out to school
it was just cloudy drizzle it was wild
so I go to the car and uh my grandfather
we got him a shirt that said help I
can't like help I'm talking and I can't
shut up like he was just I love him he
was the best Storyteller always running
his mouth you know his name's poppy you
know we called him he was in the car and
my mom was and it was the first time
he'd ever been quiet you know one second
yeah I'll pause you there Kirsten's give
me a note that says careful with your
rings on the table oh I'm so sorry no
and I'm sorry to stop you right now but
remember we're talking about Poppy and
we're gonna start you know you don't
have to take him off I'm sorry sir
you're fine okay sorry I hated everyone
okay oh my God this is worse than when
my dad died
I'm gonna do tragedy you know you better
keep that part in you better get
yourself
so uh I just want to say this too this
is really [__] hitting me because my
daughter's eight and I can't and I did
almost die and I can't imagine her yeah
getting this news at any age but this is
this is you and and you have such a
vivid memory of all yes that I know she
wouldn't it terrifies me yeah
um please your grandfather
uh so on the way home he molested me
could you imagine oh my God yeah that
was the first time I got molested
poppy more like pop me
oh my God
so anyway my father's dead
[Music]
so we we
uh so Mom and Grandpa we get in the car
and we go home are they telling you
there's just nothing we'll talk when we
get home and uh I was when I was a kid I
was a little bit of a whiny baby and uh
they they would say do you need a cry
rag because I would cry a lot you know
and uh when I would act like a girl they
would call me ianeta which kind of you
know explain some things but uh my mind
goes we need to get a cry rag yeah okay
so we go in the living room she sits me
down she goes there was an accident
where today and your daddy died and I
just remembered screaming just screaming
and I couldn't stop screaming and um
yeah
and then now you've got your aunt dead
your dad's dead I mean what happens what
do you do next I mean are you a family
for a while the family comes over and
you just sit in silence because no one
knows what to say because it's
especially to a [__] eight because
it's a [__] tragedy and then
everybody grabs you and goes well he's
in a better place your dad's with you
now forever and I'm like are you [__] a
better [__] place we were just having
catch yesterday [__] you are you kidding
me I'll be there for you forever just
and then everyone disappears you know
nobody knows how to deal with a 40 year
old grieving mother and an
eight-year-old boy that's had the most
cataclysmic traumatic thing happen and
then you see when you get upset everyone
around you gets upset so you go oh don't
get upset I'm making the adults cry so
you just [__] fake it till you make
it yeah you know
um how does your relationship with your
mom change
you guys do get super close now or you
said I mean now we are now I mean then
at eight do you remember like are you
pushing back what happened I mean dude
this woman is such a [__] because
it's just you Angel [__] human of
just like
that woman did everything
she possibly humanly could to make my
life okay and to
try to give me his best and normal life
as possible and uh you know she just I I
I'm forever indebted to who she is as a
person as a mother and
um just she's she's an amazing person
but I'll you know look it is what it is
she lost it you know and and
it was a thing of
you know we never really talked about it
because it was so hard and dude I'll
never forget man
again like
and this goes back into the alcohol
thing about finally letting me feel
emotion because
I
you know we're at the we're at the the
viewing and you know the police had to
show up there was like a huge [__]
dust up you know my mom at the funeral
had to get taken out on an ambulance she
passed it was like a [__] Jesus bro
it was a [__] [__] show I'm telling
whatever and so uh on dude I'll never
forget I I close this casket and they
need to pry my fingers off it I'm
screaming they throw me in the car and
we're driving to my grandparents house
and I'm just wailing I I didn't have the
vocabulary or anything to process or put
the only thing I knew to do was just
gutterally yell
and uh dude my my uncle [__] slammed
the car breaks and was like shut the
[__] up stop screaming stop screaming
stop crying and I and and he did it
right dude I know right where it is off
Union Ave in Wilmington Delaware going
uh to [__] Delaware Ave there's a
turn and there's a train track and he
stopped right at the [__] train
tracks
shut the [__] up I don't like him this
is not a sign you know like could you
pick a different place Uncle Bill you
[__] [__] you know
oh God I mean are you kidding me what
are we doing you know what is happening
oh my God yeah bro
so who if anyone then becomes your male
influence in life does your mom remarry
it's your grandfather he stepped up and
I mean and the thing about him man is he
he had a son my uncle Danny who
this guy man and and I understood him
once I became a drug addict and an
alcoholic
um in a way that I wish today I could
share with him
um but you know it's hard to have that
conversation when a guy blows his head
off anyway so okay
so you can't have that conversation even
even if he'd liked it
thanks a lot Vietnam PTSD
and again alcohol this [__] the
only time he talks about Vietnam is when
he's [__] loaded telling me what it's
like to shoot a man in the face
means what are you doing uncle daddy
this [__] used to get loaded and
call me and tell me he's gonna kill
himself while I'm playing Sonic the
Hedgehog and I'm like Uncle Danny I'm
trying to collect the Rings right now
can you can you hold off I'm gonna kill
myself if I don't pass this level you
know
I mean what are you doing bud sorry my
mom's I don't know yeah I'll be the
suicide hotline come on I got the I got
the phone here like uh-huh uh yeah yeah
rope chair
like what the [__] Danny but you know he
he was in he was in Vietnam at 19.
[__] him up I mean I can't I I can't
imagine anyone that went to any War at
19 the ER they're kids that aren't
[__] up bro show me one person that
went and saw anything like this
nerve damage from Ancient Orange he's
going around pulling his buddy's bodies
out you know like he was guarding
weapons cash his shooting guys in the
head I'm like and this [__] you
know I mean good God I I I today I can
love him so much and I wish
I could have this conversation with them
but you know I couldn't see it at the
time but he was you know he was Mr
promise he was I'll be there for you
always and then just never never never
and I get it man I get it and it's so
funny when I got sober later I met his
stepson Michael
and uh he was telling me stories about
my uncle Danny about him and his friends
who come home loaded and Danny would be
just in his underwear [__] in the bag
you know just [__] you know
whatever man and and it's so funny now
like dude my grandfather caught him
uh snorting cocaine and because he had
to move back into my grandparents house
and he was like in his 50s you know he's
in his underwear snorting cocaine and my
grandfather's so innocent he's Uncle
Danny's like over the table and he's
like whoa and my grandfather comes in he
thinks he's trying to have sex with the
dresser he like didn't understand he's
like Danny's out of control he's like
what are you doing because he's half
naked and God forbid my son's on coke
you know
he's like he's having sex I know he's
divorced I mean it was a [__] nut
house this is where you're living this
is where I'm living I'm getting shipped
off to my grandparents house Uncle
Daddy's [__] a dresser to a Coke in
the Next Room I'm figuring out my body
thinking my dad's watching me it's a
[__] recipe for disaster
all these people like your dad's with
you forever I'm like well this would be
great when I find jerking off and gay
porn and this won't [__] me up you know
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we react the way we do until we talk
through things better help connect you
with the licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are look you know I'm
a big big believer in therapy I go to
therapy myself I try all different kinds
of things to to be a better person
um and therapy is great it's helpful for
learning positive coping skills it's
helpful for setting boundaries it
empowers you to be the best version of
yourself it isn't just for those who've
experienced major trauma all right if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help's a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online you just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and you can always
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there visit betterhelp.com honeydew
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew there's no
quick fix for anxiety and depression
it's not finding a new therapist or
starting an exercise routine not more in
regular meditation or a better diet
sometimes you need something to unlock
your brain a new way of thinking about
and seeing the world maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health at home ketamine therapy
mind Bloom is the leader in at-home
ketamine therapy having safely helped
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1 200
mind Bloom clients 89 reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
100 off your first six session program
when you sign up at mindbloom.com
Honeydew and use promo code honeydew
take the first step and break free from
your anxiety and depression with mind
Bloom mindbloom.com honeydew and use
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the Duke oh my God so how long are
you there how long do you stay there
what from what to what what ages are say
where at your grade I don't know where I
am right now
no I live five minutes away man so he
would come over all the time I might go
over there you know and and and God
bless my mom man but
any reminder of my dad
would be an issue you know like you
couldn't even talk about it dude I would
I would watch home videos because we we
had a VHS
tape everything whatever and I want you
some videos I just get so sad and we
couldn't even say what it was that my
mom would just go stop watching those
videos you get weird
you're being weird it makes you weird oh
okay it makes you have feelings
but you know God bless my mom and she's
trying to protect me that's all she
wanted to do is protect me you know she
wanted me to be okay she she saw her
little boy being upset she didn't want
that you know and uh you know my my mom
just cut off everyone on my dad's side
the family of the life because going
around was like really upsetting you
know and then I would get upset right so
I didn't see my dad's side of the family
for like almost two decades because it
would upset your mom well upset my mom
but upset me which is a natural part of
grieving but it was I don't want him to
be upset let you know again protecting
and and and I understand that now you
know know and and what the [__] are you
supposed to do you're [__] 40 your
husband dies you get an eight-year-old
it's [__] nuts you know like what do
you do you try to [__] protect him as
best you can and so you know that's what
she did and God bless her man she's the
[__] best but it was you know I was
at my cousin's house every weekend they
were mine you know these these girls
were like my sisters I was the only boy
in the family so it was all me and all
the girls and then I was raised by you
know women and
did you I mean you're losing your best
friend your father eight years old did
you have anxiety about losing your mom
as well yeah oh yeah dude I couldn't
sleep at kids houses I would go to
sleepovers and just start screaming then
my mom would die and she would have to
pick me up and then like you know you're
like hanging out with your friends at
eight and you just start like
yelling and they're like I don't want to
go into that kid's house anymore you
know and uh I used to get so mad at my
friends who like wouldn't
love their dads or would be like I hate
my dad oh God that would [__] really
steam me up man and uh you know yeah I
constantly was afraid my mom would die
you know to this day if I call and she
doesn't pick up I'm like she's dead
she's dead she's dead I'm calling the
neighbors knock on the door you know
Janine get over there
you know Meanwhile my mom doesn't know
how to work her phone
oh yeah Janine and Gail I'm calling her
friend Eileen I'm like
oh dude she [__] had Linda Kathy's
Shirley's I mean my mom my mom was
leading the Delaware Widow team man
because my mom hit it early nobody
else's husbands died for like 20 more
years so when their husbands die my
mom's like
sit down let me tell you what it's about
you know yeah
oh man
dude what a crew
oh yeah yeah I call it No Sex in the
City you can use these [__] widows
running around ripping it up going to
the pool hall
get loaded at Stanley's I'm home having
to pick my mom up she's three sheets of
the wind you know I love it you picked
her up really oh that's great dude
when I was at in a bad spot I was living
in this one bedroom attic apartment in a
farmhouse in Delaware and I'm [__]
I'm I'm bad man and my mom comes over
and she goes you know what I've seen you
do all this why don't you see me do it
I'm gonna do what you do and I rip her a
fat gravity bong I'm [__] making her
drink box she's doing it Mom's getting
loaded with me and she's [__] yakking
in the toilet she's like dude she gets
on on this gravity bong and finally she
goes we would have [__] up
oh man
I've seen their bottle of vodka's easy
tops like Bill you said it sister you
know
[__] making my mom take gravity boxes
reality oh yeah yeah my mom's like Oh
[__] man [__] I just said her normal
she's ripping my mom a fat creamy
gravity bong out of a Brita filter the
two liter Sprite
oh all right yeah here let's shift gears
for a second
you've mentioned addiction a couple of
times all right let's go to that what
age uh do you start using what do you
mean first grade eighth grade yeah I
mean I I I'll never forget to put
alcohol first yeah my friends made me a
shot and I drank it and I was like dude
I want to feel this way all the time it
was [__] amazing I felt it from the
tip of my toes to the top of my head and
uh dude yeah I I [__] you know
got loaded at a at a New Year's Eve
party in eighth grade I'm falling out in
my my mom my dad's which is now my mom's
truck you know I'm [__] 14 I I the
the first party I go to I make such a
[__] ass out of myself man
everybody's just like oh beer I run into
the vodka and I'm like this is not gonna
make I pass out of the front lawn I'm
begging this kid to sell me weed I'm
like I don't have the money now but my
grandma gives me a check for Chris
gave me the check yeah this [__]
just said my grandma
yeah yeah
I had to fake sick because I was so
embarrassed because everybody was like
dude that kid's [__] up you know and
then this [__] his name was
Paris he was like the weed dealer or
whatever on his AOL profile he puts her
interest ripping off [__] for weed like
Ian because he sold me like a gram of
weed for like 40 dollars and wrote that
on his [__] yeah so now I'm a [__]
name Ian which is in secret yes and I
[__] ammet like I gotta not go to
school because I'm trying to bribe these
kids into getting me and something
ticked in I go I really like that girl
Christiana I'll give you some of my
grandma's Christmas check if you hook me
up with her so I'm 14 I'm trying to get
a prostitute it's not even I'm turning
on this guy pimp out his friend I mean
it was [__] hot to the races off the
bat you know my grandfather picked me up
I'm on this front lawn I had to lie and
be like I ain't food poisoning you know
[__] gnarly so then after that I was
like no more how long did that go well I
was I I came up in like Punk and
hardcore and Scott and I was like in a
band so I I straight edge was like that
finding straight edge which is a
lifelong promise of no drugs no alcohol
you know the the music scene really kept
me straight you know like I was straight
up everything with music streams I was
axes on the back of my hands [__] at
shows you know friends of mine were
slashing tires in parking lots at bars
like [__] you drugs destroy dreams you
know like all this [__] and you couldn't
tell me nothing it was for the rest of
my [__] life I'm not doing that you
know I don't want my dad being upset
with me I don't want him embarrassed you
know and uh man being straight edge like
kept me on the level being involved in
music kept me straight you know I had a
crew of guys and we were all straight
edge we'd it like emboldened us with the
lyrics and everything you know and then
um I eventually it alienated me because
I got away from those guys when I moved
to New York at 18 and
all those guys we kind of lost touch and
then all my friends I I didn't have many
friends in college I just had like three
guys and they were like drinking all the
time so I would go out I wasn't drinking
so I'd leave at like 10 and just go home
alone and I'm like oh this kind of sucks
and so I started drinking alone because
I was embarrassed because my whole
identity was straight edgy and you know
and it's funny he doesn't even need
drugs and alcohol to have a good time
I've always been you know like and uh so
I started drinking alone like dude I
would go to the [__] bar and so
afraid that people would find me that
I'd put on a costume I'd put my jacket
on inside out like I was like a [__]
Senator going to [__] get his dick
sucked in an airport bathroom I'm just
like oh it's not me nobody cares and and
I didn't know any drinks the only drink
I knew was an Alabama Slammer so I'm
just ripping them at a bar alone and uh
yeah and then eventually I came out it's
like hey I'm drinking and my straight
edge friends we you know it's like if
you're not now you never were you know
like you turn your back on people when
they break Edge you know and uh I didn't
even know this was a thing that I didn't
know the edge part of this yeah
so they they're like the phrase is true
till death you know
oh yeah yeah man
so you keep drinking you're like
whatever
oh dude [__] Off to the Races I I was
I was in my dorm room once I started
drinking and um do you remember Sparks
it was like the precursor to Four Loco
it was like alcoholic
right well those those God bless them
holy [__] [__] crash my bicycle
ripping four Locos I crash I'm on the
Williamsburg Bridge these people come up
to grab me I run away covered in blood
because my four Locos rolling down the
bridge
I saved the Four Loko instead of being
like I think I'm wildly injured you know
and uh I don't never forget I'm sitting
in the common room and I got a [__]
Sparks on my knee and it's like 2 p.m
and my buddy's like what are you doing
I'm like we drink is this what we do you
drink all the time I'm drinking I'm like
no
and so I was just Round the Clock
drinking you know and then I started to
get [__] sad and that's when I would
start to have these swings where I would
drink and be a mess and just grab my
friends and be like do you think my
dad's proud of me you know and that's
the only time I could talk about my dad
and that's when the anger would kick in
and that's when I would fight people and
that's when I would want my ass kicked
and you know that's when I like just
threw everything away and was like I
don't give a [__] and that's when I was
just in a [__] I mean I barely took a
[__] sober breath from like yeah I
don't know like 21 until I mean I try to
get sober in 2008 and uh to my my
[__] mom made me go see a priest like
all this [__] I I went to an AAA meeting
and it's Alcoholics Anonymous so I told
everyone my name was Tom like I thought
y'all like lie about you [__] you know
but these [__] are like
looking at me they're like I went it's
your first time brother you gonna be the
best day of your life I went through
this windshield I got this DUI I lost
this and I'm sober and I'm like well
that never happened to me I'm not one of
you
six months later I'm like sitting and
re-hambling I don't know you know and uh
how did it happen
how did you get into rehab oh I couldn't
stop drinking but you acknowledged it or
were you intervention like how did you
finally get to rehab well my my mom and
my best friend threw me like an
impromptu intervention okay we went out
to eat at the seafood restaurant in
Delaware and I I'm I'm drinking and
they're like visibly upset and then uh
you know everyone knew I had a prom
except for me I was the one that was
like yeah they're crazy I was like the
last one to find out you know meanwhile
I'm like waking up bleeding and like
[__] yeah I would I would pass out on
the street and take my clothes and shoes
off and fold them next to me because I
thought I was in bed
so and you're outside on the [__]
Street a literal gutter drunk a little I
would use the curb as a pillow or like
steps as a pillow a gutter drunk my
friends would have to push me home in a
shopping cart
and so I [__]
go to the bathroom I come back and they
go Ian
you have a problem we want you to get
help and I'm like this is a [__]
intervention like it is I'm like you
couldn't have gotten more people is that
what you said like is that all I got
left is two [__] people caring about
me you couldn't [__] call uncle Danny
you know he doesn't have to bring his
head
his body God damn it
and so uh I ended up I was a carpenter
at the time I ended up losing my job not
not even lose it I just kept missing
work showing up late drunk on the job
site and uh
I I I woke up I was drinking I was going
to be late and I I called my boss I go
Gene I got in a car accident I'll be to
work and he goes okay cool yeah just
bring the accident report and uh you
know you can come on the job site and
I'm like oh yeah yeah no problem so I'm
literally [__] Googling accident
reports that I'm gonna try to photoshop
to be to put my info on and I can't find
it so I go outside and I just start
kicking my car and like trying to knock
my bumper off to make it look like I got
in a [__] accident yeah yeah I
knocked the the mirrors off you know I'm
kicking it meanwhile I locked my keys
inside I called a friend to pick me up
he pulls up I'm like hey man how are you
doing just yeah
show up meanwhile the only thing I could
knock off was a [__] side mirror and
I go Gene hey sorry I got an accident he
goes
do you just
not sure to work is your side mirror was
broken and I go look man I got a problem
I can't stop drinking he's like leave
you know get your [__] together and so I
went to an outpatient place and I just
went in and I was like hey can I just
get a note that says I'm I'm I'm getting
better can you just give me a note that
says he's he's gonna get sober or
something and they're like put your arms
out like okay and I'm like shaking and
they're like when was the last time you
had to drink I was like seven and this
was like 10 or 11 A.M
and uh they're like do you realize that
you're you're going into withdrawal and
I go no no this happens every day I just
I get I get sick I get colds
I keep getting sick yeah yeah yeah and
and I just didn't know I was going
through withdrawals and then I just knew
when I drank that'd make my cold go away
you know so they go look you go to this
place you'll be there for like two days
you know blah blah blah
I'm gonna get my job back so I go and uh
you know I [__] get loaded before I
go and then you know uh no I didn't get
lowered I just had like an airplane
alone kicker or vodka and then I I go in
and I end up
stay and for 35 days damn 35 days yeah
okay and uh you know I didn't do it
right at all I thought the hottest chick
there we shacked up I let her wear my
Phillies hat so everyone knew she was
mine you know I had to be Top Dog and
when you you got a full set of teeth and
a job you're like the king of rehab dude
we're playing football I'm stiff arming
heroin addicts [__] making it look
like I'm the [__] man you know the
Bears Sanders are right here
rayon animation sessions you know where
you draw your anxiety pictures are the
best you know you know that is [__]
so on the last day rehab me and this
girl like Kiss You know and she moves
into a halfway house in Wilkes-Barre I
get my job back you know and and uh I
tell my sponsors This Girl's Crazy she's
up in wilkesbury we write letters
talking she could only talk on the phone
10 minutes a day it's perfect and he's
like yeah man that's where all the good
girls are in re in halfway houses in
Wilkes-Barre you know but I got my job
back and I'm ripping and running dude
I'm doing side jobs I'm just non-stop
like working making my money back
and uh I just ran Rag and I stopped
doing what they told me to do and uh you
know started relapsing and uh how long
before your first relapse oh yeah
all right I got out in June I started
drinking like September um no October
November I think three four months yeah
but I had this moment man where you know
because it was I I went in young and all
my friends could keep drinking and I'm
just like
I'm not an alcoholic I'm just [__] I
I I I
can I can it'll be different this time
that's the whole [__] thing it'll be
different this time you know and and my
my body has an allergic reaction to
alcohol where once I start drinking no
matter how hard I want to not to I just
can't stop but I got a brain that tells
me I don't so my brain I got a constant
forgetter and every time my brain's like
dude it'll be different you won't do
this don't drink before noon don't drink
brown liquor just drink Vodka don't
drink that just drink like beer don't
drink and it's always mental gymnastics
to be like well no no so dude I'll never
forget I'm I'm living in this Farmhouse
and uh
I'm I'm like drinking real bad and you
know vodka getting loaded high and
everything and Christmas morning I wake
up and I go look man it's Christmas give
yourself a gift of sobriety so I go down
I give my neighbor all my booze and I go
hey man Merry Christmas I'm getting
sober I can't do this you know meanwhile
him and his girlfriend are watching my
cat every time I go away to the hospital
and [__] and uh I'm all the resolve in
the world I'm not [__] drinking what
a gift sobriety day Christmas
amazing so I go to a family friend's
house at like 2 p.m and I steal their
Jack Daniels and I'll leave and just go
drink alone in my apartment that's even
worse I'm like what
the [__] them did it again brother yeah
no yeah and then like dude
a couple weeks later I just couldn't
stop and then you know God bless my mom
man I had to go to I lost my job again
and uh I got I got fired and I
immediately went to the liquor store and
got a half gallon of vodka went home
somehow like called my friend he came
over tried to steal my vodka my lifelong
best friend we get in a fight in my
kitchen because he's like not you know
letting me have my vodka and uh they
take me to detox I can't get uh into
detox because I'm too loaded so they
gotta take me in the hospital so I'm in
the hospital man and I'm [__] losing
it they had to put a [__] spit mask
on me yanked my V IV out I'm spraying it
on people I'm [__] take my saline bag
and I Spike It On The Ground like a
football and I'm like just give me vodka
now
and man my mom had to come she had to
see that it was [__] terrible I'm
strapped down you know and uh so we go
to my apartment to get my
[__] to pack another bag gotta go away
again and so my mom's like on my side
like won't leave me because she wants to
make sure I don't [__] drink and uh
I go down to my neighbors because it's
an old farmhouse I'm living upstairs
this is a two bedroom downstairs and
efficiency in the basement you know
so I go I knock on my neighbor's door
and my mom's like right behind me and uh
they're having a party and my neighbor
Jess I'm like hey can you watch my cat I
gotta go away again and her boyfriend
Chris hates me you know and uh he goes
Daddy and [__] him he's a piece of [__]
alcoholic don't [__] help him and
dude I blacked out and the next thing I
know I am on top of him choking him the
in the middle of this party [__]
everything stops I'm [__] choking him
and my mom's yanking me off of them and
mom and my mom goes
oh Gail coming through man yeah
yeah
still so wholesome oh yeah yeah she's
still got my back no matter what yeah
yeah
so you know so then when do you hit the
point where you finally say all right oh
no this is [__] 2010
and I'm coming up on eight years sober
my last drug and drink is 2015. so you
do the math five more years man I'm
still fighting it you know I'm still
thinking I can dude I'm moving at
halfway house two years sober start
drinking in there let me start [__]
drinking when you go to into a halfway
house yeah you does not doesn't it hit
you then like I'm living in a place with
these other people and like I'm not in
my home anymore that's [__] hell but
I mean where are you with that though
you do you embrace it I feel like you
would [__] it you just said you're the
king of the [__] rehab oh dude 110
percent you do yeah yeah I just feel
like you're the guy the same energy like
I'm just gonna lean into this and
[__] rock it well well it's a thing
like I wanted to be sober that's the
thing I would just it was it was never a
thing of like I I don't it's just it
comes creeping in and if I don't do my
daily maintenance of what kept me sober
yesterday and do it today I'm gonna
[__] drink again so I would start to
to make money I'd start to [__] this
girl or this or that and then I'm
[__] slowly going I can do it again
it was just young I was dealing with
this and I I love being sober it's the
[__] best but it would slowly creep
in and I would go you know what I'll
have a [__] drink you know so I being
in that halfway house it's it's a
three-quarters house it was an Oxford
House so we didn't have like you know we
weren't under supervision it was
self-governed you know we had like
treasurers and you know
um uh you know comptrollers and chore
coordinators you know it was like it was
like a setup to teach you how to live
you know and uh our house was called the
Emmett house in Newport Delaware we were
the diamond of the north
diamond yeah because our house was like
the elite house that was run the best
and all the other houses man people were
smoking crack in the living room and
everything and our house is like if
you're [__] serious you're coming to
our house you know and so that was
really cool getting in there and that
was like
foreign
I'm really trying and dude I was on
[__] fire man I didn't have a job I
burned every bridge but I'm [__]
picking up alcoholics reading the big
book on the way to [__] this detox to
speak this and that I started an AAA
meeting in Delaware uh solution based
I'm [__] feeling so on fire man I'm
loving my life I'm loving sobriety I got
nothing I'm in a halfway house I've
never felt better you know and uh on the
way to these meetings and everything we
would listen I'd put on Comedy records
you know so like and when I was working
that construction job I'd put on Comedy
records I put on a tell I put on Hedberg
Carl and whatever and you know we're
listening to Patton Oswald on the way to
these meetings you know so comedy was
always like a thing you know and I
started comedy and sobriety I I started
Living in a halfway house in 2011 and I
started in Philly and uh you know I but
I didn't tell anyone in Philly what it
was except for my one friend Tim
butterley great comic he and I are still
dear friends today I'm still friends
with all my guys I start with which is
like [__] amazing I love it and uh
I would pick him up in Kensington and go
to Philly but I had a breathalyzer on my
car and I told him not to tell anyone so
I'm picking him up and we're going over
bits and I'm like okay so I'm thinking
about this tag hold on
foreign
I'm [__] picking this dude out but I
had a breathalyzer in my car for like
nine months you know and but I don't
want anyone to know because I'm afraid
they're gonna like not be my friend I
think I'm like a freak you know and uh
yeah so I I had always I loved sobriety
man it's the best but I would it would
always seep back in you know and then
finally I got my ass kicked enough to
the point where I'm like I'm [__] so
beat up
and also to tell you the truth man I
tried everything with like programs of
recovery and I always had that Obsession
always whatever and then finally in 2015
I got hooked up with a
um
a drug called uh Naltrexone which is
almost like an opiop Locker so where in
my mind where there's like a hole for
the dopamine and like that thing and
everything it basically fills that up
and all the wires that are crisscrossed
it connects them
so dude I was on this medicine and like
truly made my
Obsession and craving go away in tandem
with therapy and programmer recovery and
everything so
you know yeah so I haven't
we're coming up on eight You're Sober
it's great because I wanted to ask you
what it was that finally clicked and
part of it is medication which I wasn't
expecting to hear I didn't know that was
a thing not many people do for alcohol
though not many people know about it for
other you know like the time only like
two percent alcoholics in the country
were on this medicine I checked myself
into an outpatient place in New York
saved my life Greenwich house and they
were like was this an experimental thing
when you took it at the time is that why
maybe a lot of people don't I don't know
if it was experimental I just know not
many people were exposed to it it I
wasn't like an experiment I was just
lucky enough to be in a place where they
knew about it knew about it yeah because
a big thing with programs of recovery is
like you got a hole in your soul it's
God you need this you're defective you
work on that I'm like I'm doing every
[__] thing I can't stop [__]
I'm gay for God I'm gay forgot and I'm
still [__] drinking what more do you
want you know
you know but uh so yeah that's that's
brand new to me right now I've never
heard that before so that it can help
with alcohol totally hell yeah what's it
called Naltrexone all right can I ask
you what you have any crazy side effects
off of it is because I know these
Chantix that would stop people from
smoking we're having people go kill
people no no no no if that's accurate
chances it like makes you crazy right
yeah so maybe kill themselves yeah no no
it it um it I mean you can even it's an
abuse is a drug you take where if you
drink you immediately puke but now
trexon made it so that like I wasn't
obsessing about dude I would window shut
I would go to a liquor store and just
look around and be like
in in sobriety I would watch videos of
people chugging vodka like it's when you
relapse it's not your drink it happens
way beforehand it goes into your
thinking it goes into your actions you
can see it coming you know and all the
signs have come and I would just be like
[__] it you know you get a case of the
fuckets how quickly did it hit how
quickly did you feel that change yeah
[__] immediately
care wow in in in in in like a week or
two and again like I was going to
meeting I was I was working on I wasn't
just like pill done right I you know I'm
like in group therapy I'm in therapy
twice a week dude group therapy was I
was in group therapy for self-esteem you
know uh and that was [__] great me
and just a bunch of [__] crackheads
from the Bronx and everything
learning how to love ourselves yeah dude
yeah it was [__] great it was awesome
I love it yeah my man the counselor
Daryl he and I would roast each other
and I'd be like you look like Grimace
wearing that purple shirt and be like
you look like you'd use your this and
that like he'd rip me on some insecurity
out I'm like all right Daryl you're you
win this one all right yeah
you look like you can't live a life
sober and I'm like oh you son of a [__]
I'm outright you one day you gotta Be
Daryl you know
um dude this has been an absolutely
[__] fantastic goddamn wild episode
it really yes I'm sorry for what I'm
just saying you know everyone because
Kelsey cook said this great when you
come sit in that chair [__] hadn't been
good you know what I mean
but for you to come on and joke and
laugh like it is so cathartic and so
therapeutic for people
um who haven't lived what you've lived
yeah I mean just losing your father
hates enough then you're battling
Addiction on top of it you know
um yeah but here's the thing a lot I I
obviously yes and and I appreciate that
and and I'm just so like grateful that
I'm at a place where I'm all right with
it man it's okay you know like yeah you
seem to be loving yourself these days
yeah I mean you're very open about your
sexuality you're very open about your
life
again you're plain and sober in in those
letters my dad wrote I just never saw it
please tell me about this how did you
find who brought those up to you they
they were hidden in my mom's closet and
who did she find them I found them you
found them yeah yeah so you could have
moved that your mom could have left that
house and they're we're still in the
same house that's what I'm saying
everything's good you don't get those
yeah but I found a man and uh dude well
the ladders my dad wrote when I was in
the hospital are like the most touching
amazing things and even just like the
the words he said and you know my dad
was this like muscle [__] tough dude
worked on a train yard whatever but he
was so sensitive and so like spiritually
in tune and like you you know he was the
only boy in a house of sisters and
everything and like he was the guy that
was the glue of his friend group and
they all said you know like John wasn't
afraid to hug us John wasn't afraid to
you know whatever but he was a really
bad alcoholic he was a really bad drug
addict and then he stopped and in these
letters I also found a journal of his
that he kept when he was like 24 25 and
in the journal he when he met my mom he
was keeping a journal
and so it was pretty wild man and again
like me and my dad we we are he's here
he's with me I see him I talk to him
he's I believe in spirits I believe in
when we leave we leave a thumbprint on
people and it's up to us to see their
spirit and others and in ourselves and
in little things and uh I I don't know
if I believe in heaven and hell but I
leave in I believe in a memory and
Heaven is if you live a good life you
leave a Heavenly memory with people and
if you live a [__] life people are
you're living in hell because people are
going to hate you and this man is living
in heaven in my mind's eye and uh man
when when he was talking about my mom
before he met her he was writing in
November of 1980 he was writing for the
date December and he goes and he kept
getting crossed out right in November
and he goes I don't know who I am right
in November I don't know why I'm right
in December I keep seeing December I
feel like there's going to be a change
in December come December he met my mom
and uh and that's in that journal yeah
but I found in the journal he was
talking about getting sober he was
talking about never using needles again
he was talking about you know his fears
of having a kid of passing these things
on he was talking about love and
spirituality you know and I got to see
him in this way because I always wanted
to know him as an old guy you know I
always wanted to know him as an adult
and uh you know I got to know him in a
way and we would always joke when we
were when I was a kid like he and I are
going to live together when we're older
and we're going to be in a front porch
watching the sun come up and uh our
teeth are gonna fall hour whose teeth
are those you know and and I see I see
my dad and other people and I see him in
things and you know I've been so
blessed and fortunate to have the
relationships I have with people and you
know a tell has become a dear dear
friend and brother mentor and and more
than just comedically just as like a
person and it's so funny this this thing
came up because oh I I opened for him
and we are chatty Kathy's and we're on
the phone and everything you know and uh
he um
he and I after gigs we just sit and
smoke cigarettes and laugh and I'm like
man I don't know my dad
but I have experiences that I could have
had with him with others and I'm
grateful for that you know and I'm
grateful I can see that and as long as I
live my life knowing that that dude's
with me he was so important to me and no
all my dreams about him are me
introducing them to my friends because
he was so cool and all my friends would
come over my dad would take us to the
park and everything you know so I try to
live my life to where if you know me and
like me you would have loved John you
know and I want people to see how great
my dad was through me and I want people
to see how great my mom is through me
you know my mom saved my life this woman
has my back no matter what these little
people's house
ready to go you know and and I said dude
I see I see my mom and me I see my dad I
see my grandfather and it's so cool I
get to share these people
with others you know that's how I feel
about like this podcast when I've been
able to do like to keep my father's
memory alive and my grandmothers as well
my my special that's coming out soon is
called Lefty son because it's all about
him he also gave me this stupid genetic
blood disease that has me in the [__]
Hospital almost yeah and so yeah I get
it I love that I've been able to keep
their memory alive and stories of them
from strangers man like that story you
told about your dad trying to burn that
snake out of that hole's [__] yeah
whatever the [__] it is when that comes
back and I had a I was a fortunate
enough to have a Tops baseball card and
they give you a relic um one it's called
it's a game-worn jersey so I took his
old work shirt and I had it put in there
oh so now whenever I'm at shows and
someone they're like I got one of those
it's like I get to say hello to my
friends you know what I mean it's like a
little boom there's like I love them I
love that how fortunate are we that's
what I'm saying like it's it's so cool
that as a byproduct of us sharing having
this conversation and it's going to hit
other people and no matter what like I
growing up no one I knew had dead dads
no one I was the only one you know and
then you get involved in comedy you're
like oh [__] I found my people you know
and the same thing I said I never
related to anybody even parents yeah
parents don't they're they're their
parents were still alive my friend's
parents so they don't even know how to
talk to me or what to say to me in their
defense and then all of a sudden I'm
like man I we have one friend whose dad
died but his mom was with him our mom
had already left it was like good luck
to you [__] yeah so it was
different for us we didn't know anyone
like that damn and you don't talk to any
you can't relate to anybody like that
and then when you get to Comedy you're
like [__] yeah God I feel so yeah man
how crazy is it that our lives could be
enriched and better through something as
silly as jokes yep you know it's the
[__] best man and and uh I don't know
it's it's just this is really fun this
is really great I needed this man me too
I really did
um before you go yeah uh two things or
one advice you would give to your 16
year old self first and I want you to
promote everything again so please
advice after what everything we've
talked about today what are you telling
16 year old Ian Finance it's gonna be
okay and I love you
[__] yeah that's great dude yeah
sometimes it's it is just that yeah good
for you um please plug everything one
more time
uh I animal six nine on Instagram
Twitter and twitch emfinance.com for all
my dates and my podcast Being Ian with
Jordan uh patreon.com
um it's the [__] best man we're
having a blast uh and uh it's on YouTube
it's like a very visual podcast and uh
yeah bye guys with Zach and Ian on gas
visual too this was so much fun dude it
really was it was I think it would be
good I've been waiting to get you on
here dude thank you thank you brother
yeah
um as always ryansickler.com Ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]